hey guys my name is Samuel Leeds and on
this video I'm gonna be taking your
questions you're burning property
niggling investment questions do my best
to answer them here on the spot live so
I'm gonna go through the last week's
Sunday Q&A and answer them now listen I
always say this while I'm answering
questions if you get a like a secondary
question that just pops into your brain
just comment it below if you have an
unrelated question that pops into your
brain just comment all your questions
property-related
bang them below I'll do my best to
answer as many as I can next week let's
see what we've got this week eco clean
green says vital air or holiday let
husband-and-wife team first-time
investors buy-to-let
because holiday lets more complex than
apply today and if your first time I'd
say start we've just buy-to-let
and then maybe move up to holiday that
down the line holiday let
husband-and-wife team screams out to me
feelings and romance and all that and
when you try to make money in property
you just want to keep your feelings and
your formulas very separate you know so
yeah it's very easy when you didn't hire
the lips to get drawn into the kind of
all this feels nice and we could stay
here ourselves no man you're better off
to John make money make money and then
with the money that you make then you
can go on holiday wherever you want but
don't join Thai investment but we've
holiday not to say holiday that's can't
be a good investment but I'd probably be
inclined to so start with buy-to-let
what else we got the chris says opinion
on buying your way to financial freedom
for example taking a 10,000 pound loan
out paying your rent iment deal sorcerer
for maybe two deals that stack very well
loan also pays for furniture deposits
etc listen no I don't know that idea at
all and be the reason I don't like it is
because you are so vulnerable if you do
that and most people that package and
sell deals the deals that they sell you
I'm not going to say they're bad deals
but if it's like a really profitable
rent to serviced accommodation deal and
for 10 grands you can become financially
free do you really think that they're
gonna pass it on to you for a fee or are
they going to keep it themselves they're
going to keep it themself so
you know I just think putting yourself
at someone else's mercy like that I've
never ever ever ever known from
experience I mean technically you would
you could argue each you should be
feasible to be able to just pay someone
to do for you but I've never known
anyone do that successfully every single
one of my students and myself who's
financially free has all learn how to do
it them self and then gone and done it
and then if you want to pay someone to
do it for you to grow it that's no
problem because they can't pull the wool
over your eyes because you know how to
do it and if so and what you'll find is
even myself I pay deal sources to find
me money but they can't BS me because I
know the industry better than they know
it so I'll say they'll say give me five
grand to for this deal okay no problem I
self a look me actually I don't like
this feel because look have you done
this if you checked this out I'd be
shake that out now I don't want that and
then he might take me three or four deal
sources and before I can go actually
that's really good
like it's having deal sausage is almost
like a glorified estate agent you know
so you can't just pay them to make you
financially free I just think you've got
to figure out yourself so what I would
do is I'd get 10,000 pound loan out and
I pay for my education
people say saying you only say that
because you run training courses no I
run training courses because I believe
that in my core so don't get it twisted
but yeah just get educated man for sure
don't try and paint want to do for you
because it just isn't going to happen
I'll be attending your crash course soon
as I appreciate your content quick
question when buying a property do I
need to get my own surveyor as the
solicitor said the bank one doesn't
cover the structural condition they will
probably cover the structural condition
and the only value for the lenders
benefit is the lender surveyor is the
lender survey not sufficient okay the
lender survey is good but I would also
recommend getting an independent
building survey listen if your house
sucks okay if you're buying a house and
it sucks let's say it's got structural
problems or it's got a mineshaft under
it or you're paying over the odds for it
when the lender goes to look at it
they're going to be lending you the
money to buy the house usually maybe
seventy five percent let's say so
they're not going to give you that money
if the house sucks they're going to like
this house sucks and they're always
going to come out and look at it and
check up on it however they're not going
to give it the Thor
inspection that an independent building
survey would do and they're not going to
have the same sort of cover insurance
and guarantee so it does go wrong as an
independent building so they would do so
that would be my advice it might cost
about three or four hundred pounds I
wouldn't bother getting a homebuyers
report or anything like that because
it's just a waste of money but I would
definitely before buying any house
definitely getting independent of survey
on it it's worth its weight in gold
Nick W says hey Sam you will hope you're
having a good day I am having a good day
thank you I have a really interesting
question how do you talk to investors
and convince them to invest in you I
don't convince anyone to invest in me in
fact I'll make my investors convince me
that they should be investing in me
because when you try and persuade
someone I mean I love sales okay love
sales but everyone in sales talk to
teachers you have to overcome people's
objections I don't ever do that
I don't overcome people's objections I
don't say hey why don't you invest you
me I don't want to because this a little
bit and try and get into an argument
with them what I do instead is I attract
them to me and I think when you attract
people to you I think I don't have a
problem with people wanting to invest in
my business to the point where now it's
almost the tables of turn now I'm
investing into other people's businesses
and that's because I've positioned
myself so wow I've educated myself so
well I've become so good and I've become
so valuable in this property niche that
it's not difficult doing business with
people everyone wants to do business
with me so you've got to get yourself so
friggin good so good at business so good
at property such a good moneymaker
that people want to and how do you do
that comes down to get an educated man
get educated and tell the world what you
do and don't be afraid to toot your own
horn
and those people say Samuel you're so
arrogant so listen if I don't toot my
own horn no one else is gonna do it for
me
same with yourself toot your own horn
and don't be honest don't be afraid to
do that because otherwise no one else
will but make sure it's true and
authentic hope that helps dem nay yeah
what happens after we become financially
independent come
literally travel around the world and do
whatever we like or have we got to be
always around our property and manage it
and if we can establish a payment method
for the tenant to pay every single month
is there another way above all right
listen listen when you become
financially free you can travel all
around the world yes if you can't then
you'll not find that true free because
if you've got to manage the properties
then that's a rope around your neck
that's not as much like oh I've got ten
houses you've got ten headaches so you
need to pack you need to systemize
your properties in such a way whereby
they are they are property management
companies in place there you have a
Power Team in place so that you don't do
anything I personally don't really get
involved with the management of my
property portfolio as I have property
managers and then I have an overseer
that manages the managers and the
overseer is the only person who's
allowed to speak to me and that's how it
works it's systemized however you
probably won't just want to spend the
whole your whole life travel in the
world because it would get pretty boring
you'll probably when you become
financially free you'll probably want to
you'll get so addicted to growth and
success and significance you're you'll
find a mission and then it becomes not
about the money like you know you may be
you be a charity or maybe it'd be family
or maybe you'll be or whatever like my
mission is this I love doing YouTube and
teaching other people how to do it I get
a kick out of it
your success is my oxygen it's my
mission so I think yeah but you need to
be able to travel the world you probably
do it for a month or two then get bored
then get a mission that's the freedom
formula baby what else we got Zak Ben
moolah I hope I'm pronouncing this right
he sent me a lovely videos man you're a
real inspiration just a quick one is it
true you cannot get a mortgage for a
property that has a tenant in situ do
you invest in those types of properties
no it's not true you can get a mortgage
with a tenant in city what else we got
similar one Rizla king always there for
tea Sunday evenings I know they're the
best when property sourcing is it a good
or bad thing to have a property already
we have tenants in place for an investor
you can do it listen if you've got
tenants in place already as long as
they're good tenants and as long as if
you buy it and keep them you're making a
good return
great it's fantastic I mean yeah just
make sure that when you buy it the
solicitor knows and he's in the loop and
you make sure you have you know your
contracts all good and everything but
yeah I like buying houses of Kenneth's
already in there somehow how do you find
out if an area is affected by article
four says Tommy Roberts you ask the
local council you ask the council if
there is article four in it and usually
you can find it on Google another
question about there's a lot about
article four hairy man yard but do you
think the entire of the the entire UK
will soon be all article four yes I do I
think that in five years time definitely
ten years time but maybe two years time
we'll look back at 2019 2020 and we'll
say those were the days when you could
buy a house and just rent the rooms out
without having to get planning
permission because of bleeding article
four and then people will be like oh man
you were so lucky back then having all
this information on You Tube being able
to go to free property crash course
being able to just buy a house and rent
the rooms out now Samuels Tenniel's
moved away and now there's article four
everywhere and now isn't it difficult
yes I mean these are the days for sure
and I love my favorite thing to do is to
find an area that's gonna be article
four that's not yet buy a house convert
it into a heights mo breadth of rooms
out and then when the article four comes
in bang bang bang I have automatic
planning permission grandfather rights
my favorite that's what I'm doing at the
moment like crazy they bring an article
forward to Birmingham June 2020 game I'm
doing right now I'm buying in Birmingham
I love the grandfather rights we talk
more about this at the property
investors crash course if you haven't
booked on already booked on right now
it's in the link it's free on the house
baby ok little pimp little pumper sorry
can you be a property sorcerer without
being a British British citizen yes you
do not have to be British to be a deal
sorcerer I've interviewed many people on
windows Wednesday
Florine even people that live outside of
the UK like there's a guy called Yan who
lived in Holland or Poland I think he's
from he was Dutch but lived in Poland he
was deal sourcing in the UK and didn't
even live here so yes you can
okay would getting visible tattoos on
the side of my back and neck and hands
affect me in any way in property um
maybe I don't know I wouldn't judge you
dude
like if you had tattoos on your face and
stuff I mean I'd do business with you if
you were going to add value to me but I
probably wouldn't do it man
I probably wouldn't do it because some
people are probably gonna be bigger than
ginger because unfortunately people do
judge the parent says I just keep
neutral you know just just keep neutral
so that's a real random question but I
like it if you had a million pounds what
would you invest in Terry well I do have
a million pounds and what do I invest in
last year I bought castle and I'm
renovating it into apartments big deals
big deals are just as easy and take just
as much time the small bills but you get
paid with extra zeros so big deals are
where you want to go however you always
mess up when your first deal it's better
than the next up on a smaller than big
deal so if you just getting started to
start small even if you've got a million
pounds it's irrelevant if you're new to
this game start small learn a few steaks
grow bigger ittsan guys that sort of
example today I hope you enjoyed it
please view comment your questions
thoughts below I'll do my very best
absolute psych em next week peace out
I'll see you soon
[Music]
you